[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
hatte gibt es eine richtig tolle leckere
und vor allem gesunder snack idee ich
mache nämlich cracker und die sind
wirklich super lecker ich hab da so ein
käse gibt gemacht aber um den käse gibt
es heute gar nicht sondern um diese
cracker die habe ich aus meinem
pizzateig zubereitet den ich euch vor
kurzem schon vorgestellt habe und den
pizzateig den hab ich vor kurzem mit
duft nicht ganz aus der fassung
im januar aufzukaufen mit wenigen aber
jetzt lass moment übrigens auch für die
fotos jedoch keine fotos gemacht
jedenfalls habe ich den pizzateig schon
mal vorgestellt den habe ich nämlich aus
dinkel und weizenmehl gemacht dass
vollkornmehl ich hab's nehmen ich habe
das schon selber gemahlen alzamora
bringt mich ganz auf der fast egal
deswegen habe ich selbst gemahlen aus
dinkel körnern und weizenkörner und es
ist wirklich super
den teig kann man sogar vorbereiten ihr
könnt nun einem kühlschrank lagern und
ich habe jetzt einfach eine portion
aufgehoben von den pizzateig der rest
wurde zur pizza ist in unserem magen
schon gelandet und den restlichen teig
habe ich aufgehoben um heutige cracker
zu machen
ich habe jetzt bestreut mit zusammen
schwarzkümmel ein paar kräutern und die
sind wirklich super lecker ihr könnt die
auch gut lagern weil sie eben getrocknet
sind und vor allen dingen könnt ihr sie
sehr gut mitnehmen
ich zeig euch jetzt mal was ihr außerdem
teig noch vier zutaten benötigt für die
cracker brauche ich eine portion
pizzateig hier habe ich sesam und
schwarzkümmel gemischten den halben
teelöffel mehr sein
ich habe ich etwa 30 gramm
sonnenblumenkerne jeweils einen
teelöffel chiliflocken und oregano
getrocknet und ich habe ich noch ein
stück parmesan bestreut die
arbeitsfläche mit etwas dresden ihr
könnt auch mehr nehmen
und jetzt nehme ich den pizzateig der
mich schon vorbereitet habe und weiter
jetzt dünn ausrollen
und wenn ihr merkt dass dünn genug
nehmen sie einfach papier und ich nehme
jetzt backpapier und keine dauerprojekt
denn ich werde das ist gleich nicht
zurecht schneiden und meine dauer bank
folie möchte ich ja nicht zerstören
man kann ich hier nämlich nochmal ein
bisschen drüber rollen und jetzt
schneidet die cracker zu recht dafür
nehme ich jetzt ein bisschen geld ihr
könnt auch ein ganz normales fahrrad
nehmen oder auch ein messer einfach in
der gewünschten größe ich denke gemacht
die jetzt das war eine schöne handliche
portionen seien jetzt durchschneiden
[Musik]
und jetzt entweder rechteckig oder
rautenförmig ich mache jetzt laufen
jetzt gespräch die platte mit etwas
wasser und jetzt kann ich den belag
drauf geben ich habe jetzt hier diese
mischung gewählt ihr könnt natürlich
strauß darauf geben was ihr möchtet ich
nehme jetzt zusammen und schwarz kümmern
und durch das wasser klebt jetzt alles
schön an da entlang heute chili und
oregano st
wenn ihr möchtet noch ein bisschen mehr
salz und ich glaube diese lasse ich
jetzt weg
mir gefällt das so jetzt ganz gut und
jetzt lege ich da noch mal eine dauer
back folie drüber und rollen noch mal
drüber damit die saat für uns reiter das
ist einfach nicht runterfällt machen
banken
und jetzt sehe ich das ganze auf ein
backblech und so kommen die cracker
jetzt in den vorgeheizten backofen bei
200 40 grad für etwa 15 minuten ihr
schaut einfach das so schön goldbraun
sind in korinth und dann probieren wir
gleich jetzt sind die cracker fertig und
ich kann sie jetzt schön auseinander
brechen
das ist echt toll meinen backofen da hat
er ein bisschen ungleich gebacken aber
das wird sich jetzt zum vorteil denn
jetzt kann schon mal die hellere und
dunklere mal probieren ich hatte jetzt
genau 15 ehe ich habe ein bisschen
weniger 11 bis 14 minuten habe ich etwa
gestellt das noch länger haltbar
ja klar mal die sind ja trocken jetzt im
konflikt das ist dinkel und hafer dinkel
will raus aus dinkel und weizen also
fragt ihr steht der pizzateig genau und
die habe ich jetzt mal käse tipp dabei
so jung war gibt's denn in meinem video
da habe ich mal mediterranes fladenbrot
gemacht und das ist der käse desto
chappuis verlinken
genau hier liegt mir rechts oben okay
das ist jetzt mal probieren
ich mag den vielfalt zu haben so sieht's
aus
ok
mit ein paar mal sahen richtig gut und
mit dem sesam
hier ist neben der lieblingsserie im
fernsehen oder nein man kann schon keine
serie gucken weil dieser knusprig sind
also da hat man ja nichts gehört habe
ich öffentlich gemacht ich weiß ja dann
darf aber nur alleine sein risiko voll
gut gab
warum kann ich dir auch mitnehmen und
wirklich einfach nur vollkommen das ist
wirklich vollkommen und mega gründe
ich hab damals noch ein paar andere
rezept variationen das gefällt mir
richtig dinge auf mich ja wir machen
immer noch schärfer machen
du kannst auch mit anderen mädels orten
spielen manchmal ganz schön tomatenmark
leyen ausgemacht mit zimt und zucker
das war vielleicht die nächste rezepte
die süßlich zimt zucker und man nimmt
man natürlich das hätten meine zuschauer
jetzt auch bewusst ich werde das jetzt
hier noch weiter aufstocken
man ist ja das macht süchtig und falls
ihr das rezept nachlesen wollte und habe
es überall saison becker dann schaut
auch sally blog.de vorbei und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß gemacht und
wissen sie was kümmert das nicht
das ist erst einmal das
wasser wasser
[Musik]